ايه البدايه مع نشره ال ماسك اليوميه
وعنوانها الحظر والكلام اليوم مو عن حضر
حساب ترامب ولا اي من الحسابات الثانيه
المحظوره لا الكلام اليوم عن حساب او
حسابات جديده تم حذرهم فقالوا الماسك او
خلونا نقول تويتر يعني بشكل عام حضروا
حساب اسمه الين جاءت هذا الحساب هو عباره
عن بوت ومحتوى عباره عن تعقب للطائر
الخاصه
مثل ما قلنا بيعتمد على بيانات موجوده في
المجال العام في الوصول لموقع طائره ماسك
في حظر هذا الحساب هو انه ماسك ومن شهر بس
كان كلامه غير الكلام وكان له تغريده قايل
فيها انه التزامه بحريه التعبير بيمتد
لعدم حضر حساب بيتحكم او بيتعقب تحركات
طيارته الخاصه رغم انه هذا الشيء بيعتبر
خطر على السلامه
طبعا همم يعني مع حجم الحساب او
لما نجمع ماسكه عمل هذه الحركه قام راح
وطلعوا له التغريد القديمه حقته وعلقوا
على التناقض اللي صاير ماسك ما رد مباشره
ولا بره مثلا بوضوح سبب تغير رايه لكن
راحوا عمل فرد ماسك قال انه اي حساب بينشر
معلومات عن الموقع الحالي لاي شخص راح يتم
حظر لانه في اعتداء على سلامه الاخرين لكن
لو احد نشر معلومات عن موقع الشخص بعد
فتره مو بشكل مباشر وحالي فهذا اوكي وما
في شيء وبعدها نشر وقال انه في ملاحق
مجنون امس لاحق سياره فيها ابن الصغير اكس
معتقدا انه ماسك جوه السياره وقال انه
الشخص هذا اعترض السياره ومنعها من الحركه
ونط على مقدمتها ونشر فيديو كمان للشخص
وطلب من اللي يتعرف عليه او على سياره انه
يساعد في التعرف عليه
ماسك بعدها اكد انه في صدر اتخاذ
الاجراءات القانونيه ضد اللي لاحق سياره
ابنه وصاحب الحساب اللي كان بيتتبع طيارته
وكل من يعرض عائلته للخطر وبالعوده للحساب
اللي كان بينشر موقع طياره ماسك فالحساب
بط مثل ما قلنا وكان عليه نصف مليون متابع
تقريبا وبيديروا طالب جامعي اسمه جاكسون
عمره 20 سنه وهذا طالب عنده حساب بيتتبع
طياره ماسك على مختلف اقل من الصوت الاخرى
وكمان عنده 30 حساب اخر على تويتر بديرهم
ومنهم حساب شخصي وكلهم تمرهم وهذه
الحسابات على فكره بتتبع سيارات اخرين مثل
بالجيتس ماركه
صاحب الحساب واللي ماسكته وعقده بالملاحقه
ايضا قال انه ماسك السن الماضي يعرض عليها
5,000$ ويقفل الحساب